Without making any adjustments to this plot, I notice that
having more than 1,000 friends is quite rare. Even for very
young users we can see that this is where it
peaks, with the exception of this older crowd. And that the
90 percentile is well below 1,000. You may have also
zoomed in on this plot using the coord_cartesian layer. To use
it, we need to get rid of the coord_trans and
the xlim layers first. So I'll delete those lines of code.
Adding in the coord_cartesian layer, we can just set the x and
y limits to whatever we think is appropriate. For our users, I want to
explore users between the age of 13 and 70. And for friend counts,
the 90th percentile is a 1,000, so that seems like a good upper
limit here. Now it looks like I got an error and that's
because I forgot to add a plus sign after this layer. I want to
add all these layers on top of each other. Now with this plot,
we can see that we get a little bit more detail. For example,
we can see that for 35 year olds to
60 year olds, the friend count falls below 250.
So 90% of our users between this age group
have less than 250 friends. At least according to Facebook.